I think we don't talk enough about how
no and failures are the foundation for
yes and wins
you got your prospectus don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
if you're if you're like me and you're
you know over 40 you actually remember
the world pre-internet which for a lot
of people in here doesn't exist and so
from afar you know under you know to be
and he hates when I pontificate about
this but when you are literally the
leader the you know Rainmaker of
Hollywood during a pre-internet world
you are not only at the top of Hollywood
you know you're talking to somebody that
thinks that Hollywood has been the great
engine that has built the American brand
over the last hundred years so if you
think about having a decade when nothing
significant doesn't run through you or
your organization it's really there is
no current comp in our society of like
dictating culture because the Internet
has amortized it out to a lot of leaders
and so when you think about you know
four to five or six or seven individuals
map to the level you know it's not a
money thing it's an impact on culture
and really just a level of power we just
there aren't a lot of individuals have
had a run on dictating what this country
consumed and thus the world more than
what Michael did at the top of CIA and
what him what did you learn from him
observing him the last you know 20 years
being obnoxiously powerful is cool I'm
kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding I I
think I think what I think it's a little
bit different actually I have a very
nuanced answer ah that is definitely not
what I learned and and not something I
think a lot about what I did learn
though or more importantly what as I
started digging into Michael's career as
my career changed and you just because I
didn't really grow up with a eye towards
Hollywood a all my buddies and pals and
gals and friends like that looked
towards LA and Hollywood of a certain
age this is like way up there number two
my whole career right now I'm currently
building a cup
that's goal is to buy IP and businesses
in the future and repackage them and
merchandise them I think a lot of
entrepreneurs here and uh not only
entrepreneurs nonprofits politicians
tastemakers whatever your goals and
ambitions are a lot of you are missing
everything's right except you didn't
figure out how to create the proper
container for it and how to merchandise
that container what Michael spearheaded
was a packaging of talent the IP not the
distribution that gave his clients and
his organization the leverage and was
able to extract out dollars from the
system that they were entitled to that
they didn't get in the past no different
than a Players Union did for athletes
and sports so what did I learn that it
reinforced my intuition that packaging
and merchandising is as important as
having the chops for it can you continue
on this Michael on packaging I mean that
really is something you're known for so
it is it's important to bear in mind you
have to in the course of this hour we're
have 45 minutes we're spending together
one has to start thinking of time frames
Gary mention it articulately
pre-internet post-internet
a completely different approach to
distribution today if Elliott had a good
piece of content he wanted to put up as
Gary does also they can create audiences
they can create small niche audiences
they can create large audiences that cut
across a large demographic when I worked
in the entertainment business from the
60s yes the 60s all the way through
early 2000 when the business started to
change because of the internet there was
a very large barrier to entry so if any
of you out there had an idea there were
very limited ways to get it to the
public very limited ways actually to be
very specific you had CBS NBC ABC later
on Fox you had 7 movie studios 5
publishing
five record companies and probably ten
different companies in Europe that was
it
what we tried to do is move the leverage
as Gary mentioned from the buy side who
were buying your ideas to the sell side
and we did it by packaging ideas so if
Gary had an idea for in those days a
film or TV show a book a record a
magazine article or today a podcast we
would proceed to try to add as many
elements around that as possible before
going to a buyer so that the more
elements we had the buyer only had two
choices yes or no and then we would back
it up today it's a different game
although I will say you can still play
the game we played in today's market
you've done a good job of that it's so
much of this is about leverage right
it's kind of how I think about kindness
in the biggest macro I literally think
kindness is the ultimate leverage in
perpetuity and so something as frothy as
that or building community or being an
execution player like it's all about the
leverage if you if you're not
commoditized you got a shot but with
leverage comes the connotation of non
kindness by the way because you have
that leverage it's a question of how you
use it I wouldn't Gary and I were
talking before the session with Elliott
and I will say that in today's
marketplace many of the things that
worked in the past probably would have
to be adjusted and either ramped up in
certain areas or ramped way down in
others leverage is a very dangerous
thing in in an internet world where
everything's instantaneous and
everything is communicated if it's not
used properly how did you pack how did
you package Rainman and how did you
break through those walls so Rain Man
started as a screenplay that was turned
down by Warner Brothers I'll try to give
you this short story this because it
actually took three years just to get it
off the ground
and the the studio didn't want to do it
which was really raw meat for CAA when
the studio didn't want to do something
we wanted to show that we could do it as
being really a company that was
patterned a lot after the what MGM was
in the 40s 30s 40s and 50s which was a
repository of talent so anybody that had
any kind of talent at all was somebody
that MGM tried to acquire by put under
contract we tried to do the same thing
with Rain Man we had a screenplay turned
down with nothing attached to it
we immediately after reading the script
gave it to Dustin Hoffman who fell in
love with both roles but particularly
the role the lead role of Raymond and we
then decided to try to cast the other
role prior to going to a director we
came up with the idea of Tom Cruise it
sounds great after the fact but when we
did it there was a front page article in
the Los Angeles Times saying that we
were idiots that there was no way that
those two guys could be brothers they
didn't look alike they had nothing to do
with each other
Hoffman had gone to UCLA to meet with
the head of the doctor who ran the
autism program and discovered that in
autistic families the kids don't
necessarily look the same it's just it's
kind of a a strange part of nature they
can or they don't have to in this case
the majority of the time they don't
so casting crews was very important
because we wanted that demographic and
Hoffman had his own demographic long
story short we had a director and the
director couldn't figure out how to get
the picture made quickly so we went to a
second director and the first director
was Marty breast who had done Beverly
Hills Cop he couldn't figure it out we
went to Barry Levinson who ultimately
directed the picture he got called away
to do good morning Vietnam we then went
to Steven Spielberg who had trouble with
the script and he got called away to do
something else we then went to Sydney
[ __ ] who couldn't figure the piece
out cuz it didn't have a
and then by that time it had no third
act because an autistic person
unfortunately doesn't get better and
Sydney had a very linear mind so he
wanted to have an ending anyways in
conclusion by that time believe it or
not good morning Vietnam was done and we
released it and Levinson was available I
called him I said you should really come
back to this he went back read the
script and he said there is no third act
this guy doesn't get better I'm gonna
make a movie that I'm gonna term two
Schmucks in a car and that's was the
working title of the movie by two
Schmucks in a car and he made a road
movie which for those of you that are a
little older and I don't see many of you
there all these movies made in the 40s
with Bob Hope and Bing Crosby and
old-time movie stars called Road movies
so Levinson did what Picasso did he
appropriated somebody else's idea which
is highly acceptable by the way as long
as you don't infringe on their IP and he
made a road movie and lo and behold the
movie came out and it was a dismal
failure opening weekend is that right
yeah it did six million dollars for a
weekend and the New York Times wrote an
article that Cruz Hoffman and Levinson
were gonna fire me and that the head of
the studio that did the actual physical
distribution was going to get fired
what they didn't figure out was a
word-of-mouth movie and the movie did
six million dollars for the next fifty
weeks that's 50 weeks and then it
eventually got over a billion dollars of
gross and in that timeframe in the 80s
was important in won six Academy Awards
and it's a a thank you and and I only go
on about this and then I'll shut up but
I it's really something to take to heart
it's called don't ever give up if you
believe in something just don't give up
we were told don't do it we were told
we'd get fired we were told that by the
first director the movie wasn't makeable
we were told by the second movie
director wasn't makable third director
same thing fourth director the movie got
made and it was a huge hit so when
you're into something out there whether
it's an idea or a deal you're working on
or something where you know your stomach
and your head have met each other just
don't stop URI real quickly I apologize
Michael when your stomach and head have
connected on something not named dream
man give us something that has failed
miserably that your stomach and head
connected you were sure you saw it
through you put your name on it
and it [ __ ] the bed at the theater god
I'm embarrassed one that I worked on
with one of my partners probably one of
the biggest disasters we ever did was
Rhinestone with the Sylvester Stallone
and Dolly Parton it looked really good
Gary on that get into Attica
it kind of reminds me of a football play
for those either like football every
play is designed to be perfect and it's
a touchdown if that's the case football
scores would be 270 to 220 that's right
instead of 20 to 30 to 15 and the
reality is this had everything going for
it on paper she was on fire in the music
area I had five back-to-back hit singles
a sly had done one giant hit
action-movie after the other he was at
that time the highest-paid action star
in the business we thought we put good
creative elements around it and I
remember sitting in the theater after
the opening reel and getting nauseous so
that's that's one important point for
all of us right like I loved when my
intro is like he invested in Facebook
and Twitter and Tumblr and all this
stuff and in the back of the room every
time before I go out stage I'm like yeah
but I thought your Bongo was gonna be
the biggest of them all right and I
think I think that you know I think we
don't
enough about how no and failures are the
foundation for yes and winds that it's a
net game and too many people take an L
as a scarlet letter which stops them
from doing anything and I think that's
the important part of the equation
I think another part is to or not and I
agree with that
I think another part is that don't take
no for an answer
and I think that if you believe in
something and if you believe you can do
something we came up with the thesis
that we could advertise as well as an
advertiser we thought we had the
cultural roots we had all the
connectivity we knew what the audience
wanted because we were a cultural
enabler basically as an agency we
weren't just guys and Gary just started
an agency and he understands this now
better than anyone which is you can't
just take a phone order like is Elliott
available to be the emcee it's somewhat
you can't just do that you have to
create the job and go to Elliott and say
hey I think you could do so much you'd
be great at it it'd be a great business
to start you'd be great to lead it you
have to be able to enable people said
that the advertising was something that
no one could do differently and we ended
up doing all of the advertising for the
coca-cola company we did it for ten
years and when we took it over there
were three hundred and sixty five
account executives at mccann-erickson
handling a six hundred million dollar a
year account we came up with this
concept of outsourcing and also using
our client base we did the same exact
thing they did except they did six
commercials a year we did 35 a year for
ten years we did it with six people six
people they had 365 now bear in mind
this was the beginning of outsourcing
yep so when we did the polar bears which
we created in-house at the agency we had
300 animators but not working for us
they run somebody else's payroll whereas
at the other company they were hiring
all these people trying to manage them
made no sense so again another example
about being pragmatic being confident
being bold and attempting to get in
front of all the criticism and
negativity in order in order to win that
specific account is it true that you did
it for no Commission and how did that
story go down I happen to be at a
conference a smaller version of this
called the Allen & Company conference
the CEO of coke and the CEO of coke were
there and we were sitting having a
coffee and a very casual environment in
Sun Valley and they were complaining
that Pepsi Cola was starting to beat
them on case sales and I don't know if
there's a book out many years old called
the cola wars they were about as
competitive and cutthroat you couldn't
get any more cutthroat a matter of fact
the one of the subsequent CEOs of
coca-cola was once asked at a group
meeting like this with 1200 people in
the audience what would he do if he was
with the CEO of PepsiCo and the CEO fell
out of the boat and he said I'd hand
them I'd shove a garden hose down his
throat needless to say he got fired oh
but that's how competitive they were and
you know our goal at the time was not to
be in that business but my goal was to
always listen for new ideas and new
things that we could do every day when I
came in and Gary knows this feeling you
walk in you have a thousand people
working for you when he walks in to his
media company he's got to start
generating ideas himself he's got to be
generating ideas in people that work for
him he's got to be figuring out how to
pay the overhead not to grow the
business how to make it an interesting
place to work it's a never being a CEO
founder there's never enough hours of
the day and it never ends never ends and
we basically said to them that they
asked me if I'd take a look at it and we
said yes and we did and six months later
we had the account I want to talk about
hard work and get into it because we're
sitting here to goliaths but really your
stories and how you relate your story is
about being the David's and there's a
paragraph in your book just came out who
is Michael Ovitz that I really related
to because he gets into the specifics
and I'd love for you
each to kind of continue this paragraph
after I read it as agents we didn't
agree on anything
we were sellers we sold our clients our
time and expertise and then we sold the
buyers our clients our tenuous capital
is the hours in the day less the few we
slept and we spent that capital at a
frenzied pace I drop everything to get
you the right cardiac surgeon the right
car a place for your kid at that Johns
Thomas die or Harvard Westlake schools
whatever you needed I was everyone's
chief psychiatrist legal advisor
financial fixture cultural translator
and shoulder to cry on let you take that
first period because you're doing it now
period you're doing it I did it yeah I
mean look I think I think that I think
everybody here can be empathetic how
many people here my show of hands are
running their company or the founder of
their company last the last line of
defense just raise it an enormous amount
look I think thank god we're having very
detailed nuanced conversations and
culture about work-life balance about
proper rest about meditation mental
health and that makes me happy I think a
lot of times I love hard work as a
competitive advantage but I get thrown
under the bus of somebody who doesn't
believe in what I do believe in which is
self-awareness like if this is what you
love and you love your process I have no
interest in judging anybody's work-life
balance how they parent or how they live
their lives cuz I don't know the context
who here would I would never want
somebody to work so hard or be stressed
so much that they commit suicide or they
don't feel well
that'll be ludicrous that's ludicrous at
the same token I have no interest in
judging somebody who's so passionate
about their work or the things that they
want to see in the world that during
this period in their life they're
willing to make that commitment to that
product everybody who just raised their
hands knows how many people have the
people that raised their hands also have
a child raise your hand your business is
the other child you love it that much
it's just the truth and so what what do
I think
I think when you're the last line of
defense within an organization
you're always on it's just the cost of
entry I also think for a lot of people
in this room it's the only way they
could breathe on the flip side the thing
I am concerned about is that I do think
entrepreneurship or being a CEO has been
glamorized over the last decade and I do
think that people are not deploying
self-awareness and I do believe that a
high number of the hands that went up
are actually far more suited to be a
number two or three but that the
coolness and the excitement and just the
sheer amount of money in the system to
fund to be a number one is attractive to
people and there's a part of me that
loves it because I want everybody to
take a swing at it but to me it's about
self-awareness he loved it he loved it
do you know how much I loved when
somebody comes into my office and says
Karen's ruining me like I'm the head of
HR like I love it like three of my calls
today were people who were not satisfied
with their raise I'm worried about the
leak in the roof in our Chattanooga
Tennessee office I love it it's what I
like to do my brother hated managing
people which is why he left vaynermedia
and now is trying to be Jerry Maguire
right like and so I think self-awareness
matters but to me when I hear that I'm
like uh-huh uh-huh like I wake up and
like the you know with we have a London
office we're opening up Singapore when I
wake up I look at my phone to make sure
if there's any fire I need to put out I
literally you know you don't to do it
anymore with Global Entry but for the
last year that I was filling out the
passport thing where it said occupation
I literally wrote firefighter because
that's what we do we're always on ready
to go and and when you're reverse
engineering a client whether it's an
organization or a human you are there
for them and so if you need to be their
financial adviser or cultural
interpretate or if you got to pick up
their dog these are things that you're
signing up for when you're in a client
service business you know it [ __ ]
sucks but alright it's the cost of entry
i I think it is the most complicated
discussion that
possibly be had what I think that to be
a CEO founder is probably one of the
most difficult jobs on the planet I work
with a lot of founders up in the up in
the Bay Area that's what I do now I
think their job is impossible every time
you think you have something under
control you have a leak in the roof and
shadow no that's right the reality is
that one of the pieces of advice is
simple and stupid as it sounds that I've
given is that when you think things are
going well you're gonna walk around a
corner and someone's gonna wacky in the
shins with a two-by-four because they
never ever go well I had an incident
with a startup up north that's done
exceedingly well taken off like a rocket
ship I'm one of the advisors I went in
at the recommendation of the one of the
investors to invest and advise I did I
met with the two young founders both
brilliant young engineers mid-20s and I
said look I'm gonna give you a little
bit of advice that I was asked to give
you you won't listen to it you won't
agree with it and when I walk out of
here you're gonna say that old guy is
really an idiot and I'm not gonna blame
you for thinking that but within six
months you're gonna call me because
you've got a problem and when I left I
look back and they were snickering a
little and probably saying the things
that I thought they wouldn't that they
probably should have well I was wrong it
wasn't six months it was four months
later I was in Palo Alto my phone rings
I was shocked it was one of the founders
shocked because he never used a phone in
his life he the his idea of a
communication was a three word text the
words how are you feeling never came out
of his mouth and the first thing that I
heard was were when do you remember when
you told us something would happen that
we didn't expect and I said yes and he
said will it happened and I said I'd
tell me and they told me that their
business had gotten shut down because
they'd been hacked by some rogue
Nigerian hackers
which because I do work for a company
called Palantir I actually advised them
was going to happen
they were shut down and they're in the
e-commerce business now for those of you
that are on the consumer side picture
yourselves shutdown on a weekend which
is your highest traffic day in any case
they had no relationships they ever
reached out to anybody they never
cultivated any relationships with
anybody but I was fortunate enough to
have had just had dinner with the man
who ran PayPal who just happened to
purchase the company that shut them down
and I called that person congratulated
him on his sale he said by the way can
you do me a favor and of course he did
they were backup that lesson to them did
not go unheeded and that lesson of
trying to build relationships build a
network deal with people and try to make
sure that you put in a certain amount of
time in that direction but going back to
the question at hand it's very hard when
you're a workaholic like Gary or myself
and you enjoy the action you just enjoy
the day-to-day fight you enjoy that you
enjoy every part of it one has to
remember as a founder you can't expect
everyone in your staff to have the same
persona that you do I actually think you
can't I talked to a lot I'm also an
investment advisor a lot of businesses
and obviously get a ton of DMS and
emails from entrepreneurs the audacity
for you to want somebody who's not
compensated in the same way that you are
to work the same way that you do is one
of the great shocking things that I
watch about Gary I want them to work as
hard as I do I'm like give him 50
percent of the business it's ludicrous
I have never I've actually I've I've
just I've been fascinated by that I've
never had the expectation of any I feel
like the almost thousand people that I
work for which is the other thing you
learned very quickly if you're a good
leader or entrepreneur or a CEO is you
work for them they don't work for you
which is why so many of you through your
career struggled with
transition from being a doer to being a
manager because you thought that was the
graduation and it's actually the reverse
since why people struggle with that it's
crazy to me that people have that out
thank you you raised a really good point
about the fact that you work for all
your employees but I do think that there
is a way and you do it I watched you two
when I'm up at your office I did the
same thing which is that you have can
only lead by example yeah the only thing
you can do but but me going at it hard
for me I think I want to know the
context
everybody's driven by different things
some people are driven by titles some
people are driven by finances some
people are driven by work-life balance
and for me it's always being on today
Sarah wants money next week she falls in
love and she wants to spend more time
with that person and so she needs a
little time off in four years somebody
that used to work for her now has a
bigger title than her you know you're
just always on I feel like not only do I
have to reverse engineer what they care
about
you know period I have to be that way in
perpetuity while they're with me because
I they're gonna have to evolve they will
evolve and I have to create the the
foundation for them to be able to
navigate otherwise I don't bring value
and they have to find an alternative but
that goes to the point that it is
incredibly complex math look at the map
roadmap you're just Drew and those that
lead have to make certain sacrifices to
those who don't and you know what that
brings up an interesting point the other
thing that I think is super interesting
is that it's in perpetuity
I always laugh that people boo or cheer
in the second quarter let me promise you
one thing how many people again running
or their own company right it's hard
right guess what this is the easiest
time to do it the amount of [ __ ]
money that's in a system and the amount
of you that have [ __ ] businesses
that actually aren't businesses but are
funded being serious this is something
we have to talk about if you think it's
hard now one of the things that I'm most
proud of is that from the day I started
running my dad's business 20 plus years
ago to this moment I've been running a
company and I've never had a credit line
that I took from Wine Library I never
raised capital I have paid my bills
weekly in perpetuity I have never lost
six million dollars this year
and did all my behavior to get enough
CAC an LTV to get the next fundraising
round you do understand that everybody's
about to get smoked the [ __ ] out right
everybody's so over-leveraged they don't
have businesses they have VC arbitrage
machines for the next fundraising I'll
see you all working at Bank of America
in a couple years it's a hundred percent
true and let me say this
I'm not sitting up here like I'm cool
and I'm razzing you I'm hoping that that
hits you in a way that says [ __ ] maybe I
should actually build a business not
something that appeases the VCS who have
no vested interest in my business to get
the next fundraising round that's how
you'll navigate the [ __ ] you'll be
practical like how many people clapped
versus how many did not
I might hope that maybe somebody might
make a pivot just like look I think one
of the things I'm most fascinated by
right now is there's so much money in
this system and if you follow where the
money comes from that's an interesting
thing to debate in the first place but
let's leave that for another day I I am
fascinated by people thinking that not
making more profit than expenses is not
something you need to think about a lot
more like I'm just watching people spend
all their time on like you know
influencer marketing and tack and M&A
and like all this is like when the money
dries out like there there's a lot of
young people in the system you didn't
live through 2007 as an operator you
were in college having fun you didn't
live through 2001 we have never been
this over-leveraged we have never been
this over-leveraged
and when the dominoes fall and there's
no next fundraising round or when you're
an influencer and nobody's got $8,000
for you to take a picture with a [ __ ]
toothpaste in your hand it's not gonna
be fun to go from traveling the world as
an influencer to no money in the system
and you have to go get a job like I want
people to be prepared and everyone's
living in [ __ ] lala land
and we've been living in la-la land for
a decade which makes me nervous as [ __ ]
thank you
oh I want to ask a question about
deal-making looking back on it the
Segway is always so hard to say I'm too
continuous going right on this I just
asked after what he said I'm gonna
retire because there's no hope that was
super hopeful yeah I guess I guess it
was it no it really was that no hope is
to live in the delusion that if you run
a business losing money is a viable
option well but I I agree with that with
that all right well guess what Michael
this is [ __ ] an ecosystem right now
that is built on losing money and I
happen to believe that that is something
that's going to change I think that the
people that are handing out the money
while they still have it correct are
starting to think through and probably
listening to your podcast everybody
because because because what Michael
knows way better than I do but I've got
at least a gray hair or two - no this is
what always happens we're not guessing
up here this is cycles and when you
haven't been through one you don't know
the context so I when we started CA we
started with a very small amount of debt
we bought a hundred thousand dollars and
we paid it off four months after we
started and we had zero debt for the
entire time I was at the company and the
reason was exactly and again this is 40
years ago
and the reason was exactly what Gary is
saying and 40 years ago was the same
problem there was too much cash in the
system there were a lot of businesses
starting out that shouldn't have started
out there were a lot of businesses
starting out that should have started
out but they were over funded and
worried they weren't worried about
making a profit I will say and I can
speak for Gary on this because I admire
how he runs his business when I ran CA
there was only one thing that was
important and that was secondary of
course to our people which was the most
important thing most important and we've
commented on that but it was to turn a
profit and not to be in anybody's back
pocket and not have anybody
in a position to tell us what to do
we're gonna rise or fall on our own
deeds our own brains our own willpower
and what we could do so it's a you know
to me past is prologue when Gary
mentioned cycles it's the same way to
say it
history always repeats itself we're
seeing that now in the stock market
we're going to see it we're seeing in
world affairs and we're seeing it up
north in the in the startup area and
we're seeing it with Black Swan
companies as well I mean let's not
forget that as good as Apple's report
was yesterday the stock was still when I
last looked down $15 today before I
turned my phone off so we're in a a very
cyclic world right now I want to ask one
more question who spat expound right on
this I think it's a fun way to end you
guys have been fantastic I want to ask
Gary you say it's your number one thesis
that every so much of what we can learn
about how the world works is based on
this hip-hop rules the world so I think
that if you look Michael said something
super important which was that history
repeats itself I think if you really
study the impact that rock and roll had
on our society all the way through to
legislation governments the way we feel
about many issues I would argue that for
many of us who are between the ages of
35 to 55 who if you just look at history
have a very big impact on where the
world goes and how that many of us grew
up in a hip-hop environment and with
that seed where I look it's it's crazy
for me to see Cypress Hill is the who
right like like Run DMC and Beastie Boys
are rolling stones like it's [ __ ] it's
amazing to see history repeat itself and
so look I study where the pebble is that
starts waves and if you look at like
what to me the fact that I can map back
some trends that are impacting 14 and 15
year old girls in Kansas to what Ghana
was doing in Atlanta 36 months ago as he
was an emerging hip-hop artist is
fascinating to me how much and I would
even go even more specific that right
this minute Atlanta its impact on our
culture overall is fascinating because
who does that hip-hop person influence
it's an athlete which then influence an
influencer which that influences a
teenage girl you would be fascinated is
if you're if you're as nerdy as I am of
how the reboot of women wearing jeans
with rips in them that started 23 and a
half months ago why that happened the
[ __ ] wise on what is happening in our
world are fascinating and I think
hip-hop has a much bigger impact on it
than people realize I've maintained for
in privately and publicly that the
hip-hop generation basically which a
number of people in my generation and
the generation behind me thought was
going to fade out is not only here to
stay but I feel it's dictates the
cultural agenda of the contract the and
and I have to say I think it's a good
thing I think it's opening up people's
minds I can't say I agree with all the
lyrics that I hear but I do think that
it's kind of the which is going to sound
ridiculously stupid to all of you but in
the 60s when the rock-and-roll groups
from England came over the Beatles the
who the the stones and they wore this
what today doesn't look like long hair
and there was an actual debate about
whether or not the Beatles or Elvis
Presley would be allowed on a Sunday
night television show called The Ed
Sullivan Show which was on Sunday nights
at 9 o'clock on C 8 o'clock in the
family hour on CBS was a variety
television show and this went on for
months and debated in the press a
whether Presley should be allowed
because of the way he gyrated his hips
this is true by the way this was
actually discussed all the way up to
government levels and whether the
Beatles should be allowed on because
their hair was so long I think if we
fade out to today it's exactly the same
thing
with a different costume well I think
it's a good thing that was a fast hour
that was an unbelievable hour let's give
a huge round of applause to Gary Vee
Michael Ovitz
[Applause]
you